doktor will man thema menschenleben
thema arzt zu sein das ist das was sie
bewegt und heute auch thema ja das passt
eigentlich ganz gut zur pandemie das
problem ist dass wir mittlerweile so
versessen sind auf unsere daten und
datenschutz dass man tatsächlich sagen
muss der datenschutz kostet
lebensqualität kostet vielleicht sogar
lebenszeit deswegen gibt es ja auch die
initiative daten retten leben eigentlich
nehmen wir der medizin das wonach immer
alle sozusagen auch schreien gerade auch
beim impfen ja wir brauchen mehr daten
wir brauchen mehr langzeitstudien aber
letzten endes benutzen venedig und wenn
man sich mal überlegt wie in 200 jahren
vielleicht ja oder 100 jahren menschen
auf uns heute blicken werden und sagen
werden was hat mir dafür eine gute
medizin gemacht ich glaube da wären wir
uns rechtfertigen müssen wir damals wenn
man etwa 200 jahre zurückblickt wie in
der semmel weiß gesagt hat auf der
geburtenstation die wir ärzte wascht
euch doch mal die hände bringt die
gebärenden frauen ob die hebammen hatten
ein fünftel der sterblichkeit weil die
sich die hände gewaschen haben der ist
am ende in einer video sagt man heute
sozusagen damaliger begriff der in
anstalt verstorben denn das ist bitter
und ich glaube tatsächlich dass der
vorgeschobene datenschutz lobt gar
keiner so richtig weiß warum wir das
eigentlich machen in anderen bereichen
geht es nicht er gibt mir schon alle mit
kreditkarten und machen online banking
da ist es genauso unsicher mit den daten
aber letzten endes ist es ein riesen
problem weil wir wirklich menschenleben
gefährden und menschen qualität nehmen
und jetzt ist es ist ein dilemma wo man
wirklich sagen muss warum tun wir uns
auch als gesellschaft aber natürlich
auch in der medizin werden
ich hätte da direkt eine frage wie
können wir das ändern das ist eine sehr
gute frage wenn ich die wüste will ich
hier gar nicht sitzen dass das große
problem ist ich hab mich mit ein paar
leuten ausgetauscht die auch in den
dieser initiative sind und wir haben uns
mal überlegt woher kommt das und manche
sagen das kommt von der volkszählung
sollen den 80ern wo man gesagt auf
einmal wieder big brother is watching
you und es werden daten gezählt und ich
fühle mich irgendwie exponiert und das
ist scheinbar noch in uns so tief drin
zudem ist es so wenn irgendwo ein
datenschutzbeauftragter
gerufen wird dann holt man immer den
härtesten und der alles schon abgelehnt
hat ja der immer schon der der war der
verhinderer und das war jetzt der
datenschutzbeauftragte sein und am ende
des tages wir können immer mehr von
ihnen hat dann auf einer app seine
krankenkarte hat er in den letzten
arztbrief seine diagnosen seine
blutwerte haben sich drauf ich verliere
warum eine krankenkassenkarte ich weiß
nicht ja überhaupt nicht unwichtig habe
die patientenaufnahme gesagt das
wichtigste ist hier der letzte arztbrief
da steht drauf was ich wissen muss wir
machen alles mögliche wir machen online
buchen flüge ferien banking alles wo wir
ganz viele daten preisgeben und nur bei
den gesundheitsdaten da haben wir
sowieso ein spaß muss eigentlich die
krone at nutzen können dann werden wir
für etwas nutzen zu nutzen und wieder
ist aber nur ein punkt reform sind die
anderen im pavillon an der börse
beauftragt wissen wir doch sind auch ein
feigenblatt für die politik um
eigentlich massive eingriffe immer zu
kaschieren und im zweifel sagen zu
können ja der datenschutzbeauftragte hat
auch ja gesagt oder vielleicht sagte
auch mein nein das ist ein 2
naja wir sagt andauernd nein gesagt
möglicherweise das ist richtig viel zu
oft an arbeit dingen die sie haben es
gerade angesprochen eigentlich ganz
nötig wären aber ich meine mit
feigenblatt eigentlich dass es viele
regierungen landes auf landes- oder auch
auf kommunaler ebene ganz gut zu sagen
ja wir haben ein datenschutzbeauftragten
der prüft das einfach mal da delegiert
man dann auch ein bisschen was weg und
tut so als wenn man im sinne des bürgers
arbeitet also das muss man immer sagen
wenn wir über das thema daten und
medizin sprechen das was sie ja gerade
angesprochen haben dann ist ja
eigentlich einerseits erkennbar dass wir
uns in so einer pandemie die jetzt
extrem gut
verwalten können als wir können uns an
alle möglichen
richtlinien handel erhalten das machen
wir doch schon hier wunderbar aber wenn
es darum geht nach vorne zu gehen wie
sie selbst gesagt na dann wird schwierig
und wenn man sich überlegt ein punkt
noch das ist eigentlich mein
lieblingsbeispiel sehr ganzen pandemie
das ist das system sommers mit dem die
350 gesundheitsämter bundesweit
eigentlich miteinander mittlerweile
könnte sagen nach fast zwei jahren
verbunden sein sollten sind sie immer
noch nicht ursprünglich sollte es ende
letzten jahres soweit sein dann hieß es
ende januar 221 ende februar 22 und sie
sind immer noch nicht alle miteinander
verbunden
phantasie kann da das digital ressort
ist doch jetzt in der nähe der fdp
grossrat leutenberg aber beim thema
daten und datenschutz da tut sich ihre
partei doch auch schwer oder werden die
bereit zu sagen okay wir packen jetzt da
alles aufs handy und wenn ich zum arzt
gehe oder um falle dann weiß man was man
tun muss also zum einen muss ich mal
sagen unsere frühere
bundesgesundheitsminister daniel bahr
der war für vielmehr digitalisierung der
gesundheitsämter zur 2
geblieben wir haben dafür auch ein paar
im bundesrat die damals das gar nicht
wollten auch nach ehec einiges zu
verbessern beim thema pandemie
bekämpfung aber das ist so tatsache ist
natürlich dass in wahrheit doch für
viele bürger ist wenn es um ihre
gesundheitsdaten geht es auch sehr
sensibel ist deshalb ich bin sehr dafür
wir müssen schauen wie können wir mehr
daten nutzen übrigens um lärm zu können
um in der panini klüger zu werden
zielgenauer zu agieren bazooka und
ähnliches sind der steinzeit
werkzeuge wir müssen da in einem in der
modernen industriestaat besser vorgehen
und genauer sein und die freiheits
eingriffe nur noch gezielt da machen wo
sie auch was bringen für die pandemie
bekämpfung aber der teufel liegt im
detail anschauen wie können wir welche
daten sind besonders wichtig welche kann
man auch anonymisiert erfassen so dass
hier tatsächlich das
burgenland als beispiel nimmt damit war
es jetzt der vorsitzende von einer
großen privaten krankenversicherung die
haben auch noch keine anständige
elektronische patientenakte da müssen
berufen sie mal selber bei ihrer kranken
hat das war bestimmt wer der bundesrat
der vier jahren
ich hätte gerne diese digitale lösung
der wenn sie erstmal im verein verbunden
also das ist halt so so schwierig und
wie ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher
es kostet dem weiß aus meiner eigenen
erfahrung weiß und weil die studien auch
hingehen muss wird ja auch nicht
vergütet aber das meiste
was würden sie denn vorschlagen was wäre
okay wie viele daten dürfen auf einem
kleinen schiff drauf welche nicht
welches schon
das muss sehr konkret besprechen auch
mit medizin
wird also was aber auch darauf an wer
das auslesen kann und wo es gesammelt
was also ist wofür sie
das müssen wir wirklich mit fachleuten
besprechen das ist nichts für amateure
wo sie echt sagen weil in anderen ist
auch zusammen auf einem chip jeder
auslesen kann so einfach nur dadurch für
uns wichtig dass lehrer gesagt werden
welchen experten im hinterzimmer zu
besprechen sondern und zusagen im westen
auch ja und und offen zu sagen was
brauchen wir um schlauer zu sein die
gesundheit spannend ist aber wie finden
wir abgeben also ich hab jetzt also die
frage an einen freund heute manager
wieso gesagt okay ich bin eben da fängst
und dann ist ja auch so eine so eines
chapter verläuft
wir wollen auch immer gemacht was ich
sage nicht steigern und dabei ich kann
mit einer ec-karte ich kann ein
cardreader nehmen ich kann in der u bahn
an die tasche von ihm am randen und 15
euro abrufen wo man keine pin braucht
sagt cindy 15 euro was ist bei der
vorschlag der will man wenn sie
gleichzeitig auch sehr für freiheit und
und eigenen entscheidungen stehen was
ist wer denn hier verschafft ihr solltet
also erste lautet ist dass man in der
medizin den erfolg verkünden muss und
nicht die leistung das ist ein switch
stehen wir irgendwann schaffen müssen
das sprechen zum glück auch mittlerweile
alle davon und das nächste ist man muss
die daten massiv so anbieten wie es auch
beim onlinebanking mache und dann sagen
alle ja die daten können geklaut werden
michael schumachers akte wurde auch
geklaut und das war richtig schön papier
ordner ja die wird auch geklaut und mein
meine kreditkarte wurden euch auch
gehackte online
gegenzug die haben 126 euro war schon
schwarze von daten die wir mal
verlässlicher brauchen sind doch zb
genau diese daten wer ist geimpft oder
ungeimpft und hat welche
krankheitsverläufe dass das zum beispiel
in bayern gerade nicht vernünftig
erhoben wurde das schafft doch das war
und wenn wir wollen dass sie sich
freiwillig aus eigener überzeugung
impfen lassen weil sie erkennen es
schützt sie vor schweren verläufen und
mittelbar damit auch die ganze
gesellschaft weil wir die wertvollen
intensivbetten für die menschen die es
wirklich unvermeidbar brauchen wegen
krebserkrankungen wegen plötzlicher herz
oder schlaganfall fälle dass wir das
hinbekommen dann brauchen wir
verlässliche daten wo menschen sich dann
vertrauen dass sie richtig informiert
besitzt sich zusätzlich in der neuen
regierung davon und ich habe eine der
parteien in einer neuen regierung ist
hab ich selber gewählt und bin gespannt
wie die das oder da müssten sich jetzt
herr lauterbach und herr wissing
zusammentun oder wenn ich das richtig
verstehe dass heute auch sogar digital
wende schnell das ist ja
auch schon was muss auch so eine karte
drauf dann kann man sicherlich sagen
dass zum beispiel auch medikamente auf
so einer wie die karte sprechen das
haben das ticket regierung aber vor
zwölf jahren schon es passiert ja bisher
mit änderungen machen aber das zeug zum
punkt also wenn wir darüber reden was
muss digitalisiert werden was muss
abrufbar sein sollte aber wissen was
arzt verschrieben hat damit arzt a nicht
irgendwas verschreibt was der medikament
von abb zuwider laufe ja aber das ist ja
die faxen der durch die gegend ich hatte
das gefühl gar nicht und macht wie die
der usa von das ist dass die ärzte fax
beim weg wir wachsen ja auch nicht mehr
regen aber auch noch mal was manche
überraschung durch den
mit dem deutschland gekommen dass man
diese selbst bezahlen bevor wir haben ab
heute bewährt wie wird dann gefasst das
ist ja spannend
ja ist ebenfalls noch ein ziemlich
üblicher weg bei der
bundestagsverwaltung dass man dinge
etwas was man wie man also fragt man
danach oder also wie wird da
kommuniziert ja es ist einfach noch ein
üblicher weg also wir haben in der
fraktion schon viel digitalisiert auch
seitz 17 dass wir intern viel digital
arbeiten aber insgesamt ist das beim
bundestag
und so läuft in der klinik auch da kommt
ein patient in die notaufnahme ich habe
keine ahnung was da ist dann sehe ich
das röntgenbild denk mir der hintergrund
ist der sich zuhause eingeloggt hat
mache ich mit dem handy ein foto
schicken prozess den röntgen befund
alles unsicher wie viele leute mir
online ihre patientenakten schicken und
alles rein stellt wo sie denkt ja da ist
es halt besonders unsicher
weil wir einfach ist komplett versäumt
ein gutes system aufzubauen und wir
deutschen wir eigentlich eigentlich
müssen wir können wir noch kohle gaben
noch intellekt aber es bunt was wir noch
alles nicht können und wo es richtig die
große probleme gibt das besprechen wir
nachteile